or someone else we don't yeah no our
detectives have it any they can bring
that by yeah we we'll try to get
try I got
you we're supposed to leave
at about 5 10
180 he was a young kid he was all
nervous how old do you
think like a high school sophomore so
how what that is 16 yeah probably 15
16 what was he wearing black jacket the
hood on and a gray
mask now you approach like what is it
look like it was a 9mm it's
black now was your window down when you
approach when he approach so he what did
he
see I think I said what's up first I
thought it was one of my okay so you
didn't see the guy in first no no no no
I just opened up my my what's up and he
was talking
about
probably just Uber to the
airport
no got a call when he said that like
real quick give me a ke give me wall
pull out at that point Yeah well yeah he
had it in his right hand I just didn't
see it okay got out of the
car trying to Cal down a little
bit round cars have um
GPS so uh they're they're looking at
that so serious radio has it and they're
looking to see they're trying to track
it uh cuz it's been going all over the
uh our district now trying to rob other
people so we're trying to we're trying
to track yeah yeah we we've had we've
had like two other people
called yeah yeah since in the in in the
car he's gone up to other to try to Rob
them so twice now or three times
something yeah so they're trying
to get on the ground on the
ground get on the ground
right1 down to the ground right now stop
mov drop that gun you
get the get
[Applause]
down do not
move this guy dropped a
gun
understand dropped the gun
over man what are you
doing
got
my my hoodie how did wi
oh here driving people
do not
move you see your hands you understand
put your other handam behind on your
back come here at Point come here on
your on the ground now now
now don't
move all right we got a go don't move
three males one
female got
on
stand
up
fuck keep on
the drop
that this is going to
be this ain't going to
happen just don't
move we on you stand
up
me which one drop
a this guy come
on side turn around
back
know Sor my grand you know these
guys who got
you oh shot what shot
is
silent give us a minute explain
everything hey s this gu's got a cast on
I can't put
do you want me to give this to
you can you my my phone to huh
phone nobody nothing not that phone
thatone G nobody nothing it's
ours they used to put on thean
oh he you want to come out here and give
us some
water can't get the cuff on
this American dark color medium he was
wearing a dark blue SK and he was
approximately 14 15 years
old we need somebody to go to a
vehicle oh this going to get C man good
job y'all first day as a
woman she's 19
female we have is 19 the other we have
over here is 15 he said
yes good
shit got anything else
on okay going
[Applause]
here sit in there
sit down take some deep breaths relax
okay oh move your leg you want to him in
her
too we got another
[Music]
car not oh
[Applause]
that's you're 15 yeah anybody
got let me get a here Brian got
something n he got a cash yeah yeah is a
cast
on they got where's the other
one that one that
fuck at least they went by
me
[Applause]
that's the that's you girl grandfather
oh you 14
two oh to their house yeah went yeah
those will
work
yeah proba got one
down I don't know
last going
home
that long I'll tell you a
storying I asked like an hour Brian how
these things work let me
ask you know what the funny thing about
the conversation I had the search I said
but watch tonight it'll be up because
there'll be nothing going on and they'll
say Chopper over the F if you need a for
something I couldn't hear what he first
said it was
like you use these enough to know how
tightening joints up yeah
do yeah
P are
broken what up
hey man somebody don't want to take you
man ones you have to pull really
hard been through that
before you break was
your
okay better Dam watch this shit tight
huh this shit tight as
Fu I get my finger in there man
seeing
her let me record me
getting my finger inside there you see
that ain't tight let Dam bro
chill
yeah we'll fix
them man you guys
really I Ain doing that oh
[Music]
okay
get